all right we have more evidence tonight
of chinese aggression and biden backing
down to china trying to appease our
country's number one geopolitical foe
now this includes a largely
underreported story about major chinese
companies now buying massive amounts of
american land farms and cattle ranches
here with much more is our very own
sarah carter sarah not only are they
buying it a lot of the land is next to
military installations and that should
concern every american because i doubt
we're allowed to buy land in china are
we
no we cannot sean and it should concern
every american and that's why the
federal government has a continuing and
ongoing investigation into what has been
massive
land grabs by the chinese government
through chinese firms chinese firms
connected to the chinese communist party
purchasing land in the united states
just to give you some perspective in
2019 sean the u.s department of
agriculture estimated that the chinese
government owned about 192 000 acres of
land in the united states but over the
past 12 months leading up to march so
the 12 months leading up to this march
the chinese government has actually
purchased 6.1
billion dollars worth of land most of
the land is very close to sensitive u.s
military installations for example in
2021 130 000 acres of land was purchased
right here in del rio texas along the
u.s mexico border by a former chinese
military official that land is very
close to laughlin air base it actually
surrounds that sensitive air base and
remember the border is also a highly
national security concern for the united
states as tons of fentanyl most of which
those precursor drugs are coming through
china being mixed in mexico then shipped
into the united states have led to the
deaths of over a hundred thousand
americans over the last year another
major issue is north dakota we see 300
acres being purchased in north dakota
near an other sensitive u.s military
installation a u.s air force
installation that has drones and the
biggest one sean the one that everybody
is talking about right now is huawei
huawei purchased a significant amount of
land in montana it was near our nuclear
arsenal and right now the federal
government is actually um conducting an
investigation to see whether those
huawei cell towers were intercepting and
could block our communications within
our nuclear silos and systems this is
very concerning i spoke with u.s
intelligence as well as foreign
intelligence officials about this and
they say they've been sounding the
alarms for quite some time and they're
very concerned that it already might be
too late all right you'll have a report
with ranchers and farmers tomorrow so
we'll have part two of this reporting
sarah thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else